[Music]
since then the condition of this
consciousness is linked with this
absolute disruption the distinction
within its spirit of being noble as
opposed to ignoble falls away and both
are the same the beneficent spirit of
wealth can further be distinguished from
that of the consciousness receiving the
benefit and has to be considered
separately the spirit of wealth was an
essence less being for self something to
be sacrificed for others but by
imparting itself it becomes intrinsic
being in fulfilling its destiny which is
to sacrifice itself it rids itself of
the singleness which characterizes its
merely self-centered enjoyment and as
such subordinated individuality
it is universality or essence what it in
purse what it gives to others is being
for self it does not however give itself
over as a nature that has no self as the
uncontrolled surrender the condition of
life but as a self-conscious being in
control of itself it is not the
inorganic power of the element that is
known by the consciousness receiving it
to be essentially transitory but is the
power over the self the power that knows
itself to be independent and arbitrary
and at the same time knows that what it
dispenses is the self of another wealth
us shares its dejection with the
recipient but in place of rebellion
appears arrogance for in one respect it
knows as well as the recipient that
being for self is a contingent thing but
it is itself this contingency and the
power of which personality stands in
this arrogance which fancies it has by
the gift of a meal acquired the self of
another's eye and thereby gained for
itself the submission of that other's
inmost being it overlooks the inner
rebellion of the other it overlooks the
fact that all restraints have been cast
off overlooks this state of sheer
disruption in which the self identity of
being for self
become divided against itself all
identity all existence is disrupted and
in which the sentiment and viewpoint of
the benefactor suffer most Distortion
it stands on the very edge of this
innermost abyss of this bottomless depth
in which all stability and substance
advantaged and in the step that sees
nothing but a common thing a plaything
of its whims an accident of its Caprice
in spirit is a subjective opinion wholly
devoid of essentiality a superficiality
from which spirit has fled
here in this long paragraph 519 Hegel is
now going to do with wealth and the at
first noble now ignoble or neither noble
nor ignoble consciousness what he did in
relation to state power and so there's a
a development that's going to be taking
place in the the paragraphs yet that are
that are to come and we're actually
getting close to the end of this entire
stage of the dialectic we only have a
few paragraphs yet to go so what we've
got is the the fact that the noble
consciousness has been revealed as also
ignoble and we've got wealth placed on
the scene as something that's replaced
state power as the center of things so
he tells us the condition of this this
consciousness the consciousness that was
at first a noble consciousness is linked
with this absolute disruption this this
sort of tearing itself apart the
distinction within its spirit of being
Noble as opposed to ignoble falls away
both are the same what allows us now to
have any sort of determination it's
going to be what what Hegel here is
calling the beneficent spirit of wealth
and we want to think about what is it
that wealth actually does so far we've
been discussing it as if it's a social
force it's it's sort of an economy we're
giving and spending is taking place and
Hegel is going to stress to us here that
it is it is wealth he's brought this up
before wealth is what gives
consciousness it's being for self in
this case its actual existence and so
this is indeed a great benefit that is
that is coming from the benefactor but
now instead of just treating wealth as
kind of this this cipher as this thing
that that sacrifices itself he's going
to frame it as
itself a consciousness on the other side
so let's see how this takes place he
says the beneficent spirit of wealth can
be distinguished from that of the
consciousness receiving the benefit the
one who is been the benefactor or the
one who is giving can be distinguished
from the one who is receiving and so if
we have a noble or ignoble or whatever
sort of consciousness it's getting
something whether it be an opportunity
to earn an income whether it be an
actual say inheritance you know we're
actually going to be looking here at
Dida rose Ramos nephew you know and we
might think of all the the literature of
legacy hunting that goes on from Roman
times all the way into the the 19th and
indeed 20th century all of that is is
you know involving this this thing that
that Hegel is talking about here this
this consciousness receiving the benefit
and the beneficent spirit so what is the
spirit of wealth he says the spirit of
wealth was and this is previously an
essence less being for self something to
be sacrificed for others something that
would you know provide us sort of to
play on words a sort of currency for
whatever it is that this person over
here wants to buy whatever it is that
they need for their their life to be
themselves so now he says by imparting
itself it becomes an intrinsic being it
becomes a being in itself so it's no
longer something that lacks intrinsic
being it's becoming something solid in
its own right by giving itself by
spending itself it's becoming something
that is so he goes on and he says in
fulfilling its destiny which is to
sacrifice itself it rids itself with a
singleness which characterizes its
merely self-centered enjoyment and as
such subordinate subordinated
individuality it becomes universality
or essence Vaes them so he says what it
imparts
what it gives to others is being for
self it allows them to understand who
they are it allows them to decide for
themselves I will build this kind of
house it creates the conditions for the
possibility of their own not just
self-expression or livelihood or you
know eating but being what they're going
to be in relation to each other in
relation to themselves in relation to
their other and here's where the
relation with the others gonna get
really interesting because the wealth is
another other there's a there's an other
behind it it's no longer just a spirit
doing its own thing there's a
consciousness a subject who is giving
the wealth so he says what it imparts is
being for self it does not however give
itself over to a nature that has no self
as the uncontrolled surrender of the
condition of life but as a self
conscious being in control of itself it
is not the inorganic power of the
element that's known by the
consciousness receiving it to be
essentially transitory it's not just
whatever wealth is being given it is the
power over the self we have a different
kind of experience going on here that's
already been hinted at in previous
paragraphs it is the power over the self
a power that knows itself to be
independent and arbitrary and at the
same time knows that what it dispenses
is the self of another what are we
talking about here the wealthy person
the person who actually has control over
the wealth the person who gets to decide
who is going to receive wealth and who
is not going to and the conditions under
which that's going to happen Hegel says
that this person is the one who is truly
independent muna pending right not not
dependent on somebody else this person
over here the better the the beneficiary
is dependent and so this is another
reason why we're not going to have the
noble consciousness anymore
right there is a dependency that is
arising there is an arbitrary Ness to
that if this person wants to cut them
off or make them jump through whatever
hoops they get to do that they want to
rub their nose in it this is remember
part of the development of culture
so he says wealth shares its dejection
with the recipient but in place of
rebellion rebellion on the part of the
recipient arises arrogance a sense of
having something over the other person
so he says it knows as well as the
recipient that being for self is a
contingent thing now isn't that an
interesting thing to say being for self
is a contingent thing it is something
that can be taken away it's something
that can be cut off can be repurposed
can be channelled I mean if we think
about the way this works in our own
world people take a job for granted
we've worked out certain you know ways
of living in this town you know the mill
will always be open and then the owner
says nope we're selling out it doesn't
make sense for me to keep this going or
well if you do want me to stay here
you're gonna have to make some
concessions suddenly the dependency the
contingency of one's being for self is
displayed are you understanding yourself
as somebody who is earning an income who
can buy words by work buy something else
get somebody else to give you something
the same thing could be said by the way
when the wealth dispenser is the state
power I I'm owed a certain
standard of living by the way things are
set up well what happens when the
government decides it doesn't want to do
that anymore perhaps because of
financial exigency perhaps because the
person in charge just says we're done
with this dependency we're gonna change
things we're gonna move to a new order
well once again contingency is being
displayed so he says it is itself this
contingency in the power of which
personality stands so in this arrogance
he says which fancies it has by the gift
of a meal acquired the self of another's
eye and thereby gained for itself the
submission of that other's inmost being
it overlooks something so what we've
really got here are our two sides
neither of which is really entirely in
charge the the rich person can say dance
monkey dance do what I want you to do
and the monkey will dance but the monkey
inside is saying screw you screw you
screw you there's this inner spirit of
rebellion going on it's impossible to
control to channel to to observe and
decide every single thing to determine
it this is what the the wealth the
benefactor realizes so he goes on and he
says it overlooks the fact in this inner
rebellion that all restraints have been
cut off overlooks the state of sheer
disruption in which the self identity of
being for self having be become divided
against itself all identity all
existence is disrupted very often the
rich will also take the rules of the
game as having been established listen I
give you this money I expect something
in return and the person over here can
say screw you I'll give you what you
want but I'm going to spit in at first
or anything along these sorts of lines
I'm going to subvert it because they
already don't have a stake you might say
they've already lost
they're stable sense of self when one's
own being for self is displayed as
contingent this has effects not only on
the person himself but on who is giving
it to them so he goes out and he says it
stands on the very edge of this this
innermost abyss of this bottomless depth
in which all stability and substance
have vanished and in this depth sees
nothing but a common thing a plaything
of its whims an accident of its Caprice
its spirit the spirit of wealth is a
subjective opinion wholly devoid of
essentiality of superficiality from
which spirit has fled so both sides if
they they push their own side too much
they lose in the process this is not a
resolution this is just sort of setting
up the stage
just as self-consciousness hand its own
language with state power in other words
just as spirit emerged as actively
mediating between these extremes so also
his self-consciousness its own language
in dealing with wealth but still more so
when significance and thereby gains
possession of it is likewise the
language of flattery
but of base flattery for what it
pronounces to be an essence it knows to
be expendable to be without any
intrinsic being the language of flattery
however as we have already observed is
spirit that is still one-sided for all
those moments are indeed the self which
has been refined by the discipline of
service and to a pure existence and the
intrinsic being of power yet the pure
notion in which the simple unitary self
and the in itself the form of pure I and
the latter this pure assets are thought
are the same this unity of the two sides
which are in reciprocal relation is not
present in the consciousness that uses
this language the object is still for
consciousness and intrinsic being in
contrast to the self that is the object
is not for consciousness at the same
time consciousness is own self as such
the language of this disrupted
consciousness is however the perfect
language and the authentic existed
spirit of this entire world of culture
this self-consciousness which rebels
against this rejection of itself is a om
so absolutely self identical in its
absolute disruption the pure mediation
of pure self consciousness with itself
it is the sameness of the identical
judgment in which one and the same
personality is both subject and
predicate but this identical judgment is
at the same time the infinite judgment
for this personality is absolutely
directed and subject and predicate are
utterly indifferent immediate beings
which have nothing to do with one
another which have no necessary unity so
much so that each of
power of a separate independent
personality the beating for self of this
consciousness has its own being for self
for object as an out-and-out other and
yet at the same time directly as its own
self itself as another not as if this
had a different content for the content
is the same self in the form of an
absolute antithesis and a completely
indifferent existence of its own here
that we have the spirit of this real
world of culture spirit that is
conscious of itself in its truth and in
its notion
in an entire work the phenomenology of
spirit which certainly one cannot say is
the most clear philosophical book that
you can get your hands on this paragraph
520 might seem in certain respects one
of the more obscure passages not only
because Hegel is using his usual
language of rather abstract ways of
expressing things but also because it's
a little bit hard sometimes to see how
the parts actually cohere so you want to
read this one through several times and
what's really being talked about here is
what Hegel is referring to is the real
world of culture we're getting an
insight into how wealth as something
that's received is something that's
given something that connects people
together how it impacts consciousness
how consciousness arranges it
understands itself in relation to wealth
so he says just as self-consciousness
had its own language with state power
what was this language in other words
just a spirit emerged as actively
mediating between these extremes right
the spirit was revealing itself in
language so does self-consciousness its
own language in dealing with wealth but
still more so when it rebels when it
reacts against it what is that language
it's gonna be what Hegel calls the
language of base flattery and he's
actually not going to tell us that much
about the way that language works here
and studies going to talk more about how
the consciousness itself is working here
he will talk about you know statements
we could say or connections between
subjects and predicates but that's going
to happen a little bit later now he sort
of jumps back to talking about how
things worked with with state power he
says the language that gives wealth a
sense of its essential significance
thereby gains possession of it is
likewise the language of flattery but a
base flattery so the flatterer is in a
certain sense getting one over
on the flat heard this was not the case
with state power right
he says the language of flattery is
spirit that is one-sided
for although it's moments are indeed the
self that's been refined by the
discipline of service into a pure
existence and the intrinsic being of
power here he's talking about the
previous way in which the noble
consciousness related itself the state
power yet the pure notion in which the
simple unitary self in the in itself the
former a pure I the latter this pure
essence or thought are the same here
we're starting to already get to talking
about how the subject and the predicate
are related to each other in the way
that Hegel is using it it's kind of a
strange sense of these terms he says
this unity of the two sides in
reciprocal relation is not present in
the consciousness that uses this
language so he's marking here well you
got to read between the lines a little
bit that something different is
happening in the flattery that is
happening the flattery that is that is
being engaged in as a speech act by the
no longer noble consciousness in
relation to wealth by contra distinction
to the flattery that had taken place
previously with the noble consciousness
we've got that sort of sucked into the
orbit of state power so he says the
object is still for consciousness and
intrinsic being in contrast to the self
so it's an in itself in contrast to the
self the object is not for consciousness
at the same time consciousness his own
self as such this is something that is
going to be achieved through the
movement that we're about to traverse so
he says this disrupted consciousness has
a language and it's a perfect language
and the authentic existence spirit of
this entire world of culture what's he
on about their culture is an alienated
world in which we talk about things but
they're not entirely what we say they
are or what they present themselves
to us as being as we're gonna see
discussed a little bit more in the
paragraphs yet to come so he goes on and
he says the self-consciousness that's
rebelling against this rejection of
itself the way it's being treated by
wealth right
the self-consciousness which rebels
against it is the absolutely self
identical in absolute disruption the
pure mediation of pure consciousness
with itself what the hell is he talking
about there that's very abstract that
sounds similar to so many other places
okay so let's let's think about it this
way we just saw in the previous
paragraph that wealth is not something
totally static it's not even something
dynamic in a sense that it would just be
a process that gives of itself that
sacrifices itself but would lack
subjectivity there is a subject the
wealthy person the benefactor what is
the relation of the self-consciousness
to that benefactor reason well they
flatter them what is actually going on
in that flattery Hegel is unpacking from
this all this stuff that's happening
beneath the surface and he's tying this
in with the fact that this consciousness
the self consciousness the the one who's
receiving has sort of lost its sense of
who it is it's received it back by being
bought off or being been affected or
whatever we want to say by the person
who gives it but the person who can also
take it away
and whose own grasp on that wealth might
turn out to be rather contingent right
there's nothing sadder than a wealthy
benefactor who was on top of the world
and very you know this Hegel said in the
previous paragraph arrogant getting away
with like throwing money all around and
suddenly they're destitutes
thinking about these celebrities who
blow through their earnings so quickly
and then we look we look at them on
these reality shows and were like look
at that schmuck they're you know they're
washed up
what's really interesting about wealth
here as opposed to the way state power
was being understood
anybody can step into that position
anybody can also step out of that
position alright so we go on and he says
this this we've got here a sameness of
the identical judgment in which one in
the same personalities both subject and
predicate he says but this identical
judgment is at the same time the
infinite judgment for the personality is
absolutely directed subject and
predicate are utterly indifferent
immediate beings which have nothing to
do with each other no necessary unity so
much so that each is the power of a
separate independent personality so what
we got here we have to think two
thoughts at the same time we have an
identical statement the subject and the
predicate the same personality just sort
of in two different places the infinite
judgment in which subject and predicate
don't have any relation or could he have
any relation we want to give them it's
totally up to them they are other to
each other their relations are
contingent both of these are going on at
the same time this means that the person
who occupies the role at this moment of
the wealthy benefactor who's getting
flattered could be out of that role and
that one could be in this role now this
doesn't mean that you are you know high
praising the wealthy person there by
simply praising yourself that guy
actually does have the big house on the
hill that guy actually does have the
role that he's carrying around and can
you know make it rain as they say but he
doesn't for right now so Hegel goes on
and he says the being for self of this
consciousness has its own being for self
for object notice this as an out-and-out
other and yet at the same time directly
as its own self
this means as he points out itself as
another not as if this had a different
content for the content is the same self
in the form what is yourself at this
point in the form of a complete and
absolute antithesis and a completely
indifferent existence of its own Hegel
says this reveals to us what the real
world of culture is a whole bunch of
beings alienated from their own self
unable to get away from themselves stuck
in this dynamic with wealth not happy
about that even the people in the
dynamic are not getting what they they
actually need because in trying to buy
out the other people the other people
are you know under their breath
muttering screw you to them or spitting
in their food or you know sleeping with
their spouses or doing whatever right
they're subverting things in some way
writing the wrong names in the forms
whatever it is how we want to say this
is what Hegel says culture reveals in
itself as so is this all there is to
culture
well that that remains to be seen
you